president obama is on a three-day
fundraising tour on the west coast
starting today going on for the next the
Act two days and he
a is getting a lot of heat from people
because I love you guys know about this
but there are some problems in the
Middle East have you heard about that in
some situation going on with Gaza
and Israel and have you heard about the
plane and Russia and Ukraine
we have the border thing and Rick Perry
send in troops is a man down there
there's a lot of shit going on in the
world right now and our second term
president
is due in three days fundraising and
apparently just bought a house in Palm
Springs to retire in
after his presidency he's got a lotta
crap about this
and well we've got a little bit more
info about from the stuff you doing over
the next couple days
so based on descriptions of Obama's
fundraisers from Democratic officials
he could raise over six million dollars
during the trip
which comes at the same time as a
sedative the Israeli ground invasion in
gaza
and all this stuff with the jetliner
over Ukraine so it's sort of an estimate
that he could raise around six million
could be a little bit less could be a
little bit more
I am but forgetting the numbers like is
bad optics is is just bad like what's
the deal is a second term guy he's not
even raising the money for himself he's
raising it for the party this just seems
bad to me
a.m. enid it does come across as import
a spot at the same time
it's not as though I'm fervently
convinced there would have been doing
anything anyway
about the situation anywhere else in the
world yeah
had he not been fundraising for in the
great cover for not wanting to do
anything
so bareback right so Jimmy we talk about
money in politics a lot is this just
like
is just par for the course right this is
just what they do no matter what's gone
now I think this is that
legitimate criticism cuz if you remember
I
when george bush was president he didn't
fundraising he picks Katrina like that
an array what if I P Woodend so that's
how to rack up fix oh yes all apparently
if Barack Obama was an hour here raising
funds that he could fix everything
practice like it but they think it but
everything he does have a third term
it is a she can get picks now as with
other things were different
everything we get pics so that's sort of
the defensive what's going on here from
then on
correct there a drug Obama fundraising I
think it's up
while overall it's horrible that we have
a system where the president needs to
fundraise in the middle of a crisis
yes overall we need to change that
system I dot Brock Obama was going to be
a bigger force the change that system
turns out he's not he's just one of the
boys so that I guess the sad part we all
thought hope and change that we're gonna
really change the system
and that clearly so yes he still has
bones as they as they keep saying the
press a really good
keep saying he's got phone he's got the
internet you can call Putin any can call
netanyahu
but still does doesn't it just doesn't
sit with me when i get some ideas about
i'm ok I just feel like you know a dude
three days a fundraising right now
really I get you know guns are no
at the end of the day I aid comes back
to there's never been a strong policy I
I don't believe it least historically 4p
for presidents
doing something about international
crises until its
wouldn't so far ft elated that it's like
if you don't get involved now you're a
complete asshole
house itself the policy madness that we
know this shit all get worse it got me
but but with the bottom oven for gun
barrel and then they're
01 gonna step in now yeah yeah but
depending on what time it was I
about you don't like it they could hit
it right now I look like a little bit
more about who he's meeting on these
monies
his first topic at the home developer
Bruce bloom
to benefit the DNC he's got a headline
event hosted by Jim senegal the
cofounder Costco
which will benefit the senate Majority
PAC as we all love these back
and he'll attend fundraisers at the
homes of scandal creator and
the yard Live Nation I also to benefit
the DNC I am yeah
power to the people hollered to the
people democrats all about the people
right but that's what they say why
they're supposed to be more for the
people so if this was a republican
president jimmy wouldn't you be angry
yes I would be cuz I'm big hypocrite
yeah
know I have to admit that that's all
that matters i mean i i don't know
I really did I did I need did criticize
george bush for being at the fundraiser
during Katrina I certainly didn't do
that
but this is a there was a crisis
happening in America right he's a crises
is happening
in other countries which he really had
women he can't really do anything about
me anyway
and I say about the border yet there
really is a crisis at the border how can
we have a bomb the border
good point thank you Greenbay
any we needed to think I now yeah I know
they're thinking where the little
their the little pink in there I am is
it is a clear to you guys the being
president is shortage is not what we
thought it was I think that the Moray
watch 10 this presidency has been like I
like the guy he plays basketball he
seemed cool I'd like to hang out with
them
but the more that I just watch what's
going on here just easy the president no
matter who it is
it's the same shit AP with this was a
Republican who will be the same
like the guy would be doing the same
thing and just not much change in
it did it's for me proof that the first
time itself is broken
yeah the first time itself is broken
could you can take someone that you have
faith
in while there campaigning and you can
fake I can see that change is gonna
happen then they're gonna be amazing and
it's gonna be so different
and then fast forward four or seven or
however many years
in and it's the same shit on a different
day
or same shit different president yeah
gotten get you thinking that if the
system that is
so bogged down with the politicking
up being president that you can no
longer effectively do your job I think
he is hit that's why I'm so disappointed
with him because we all had these high
hopes I voted for the guy
wife-beating so that's why I am so
disappointed cuz it's just been some
other guy would've been like you have
okay take another guy
doing the same old shit but because I
hope and change
even the second time I was still like
he's going to be a little better he will
be constrained
by an election and yet he still doing
the same shit bring it home to me or
what I like to say is that we get a
choice in america in politicians right
because when romney ran against Obama if
Romney were one
we woulda got Romneycare but Obama one
cell we got robbed me care
we get a choice that america your
country's just not that into you
would you can read all about the new
book there you go humidors new book
your country just not that into you he's
got a copy look at it right there
and you get on iTunes you know your
local bookstores and all that good stuff
up